when these travelers boarded their plane
in south africa on thursday night they
hadn't heard of the new covid variant by
the time they landed in london the whole
world knew about b11529
i got the message from my son in south
africa saying you just made it mom they
just said to us they would like us to go
once we arrive now
get straight to your destination and
quarantine for 10 days
the uk rushed to restrict travel from
southern africa but not yet at least to
constrain life at home we are concerned
that this new variant may pose
substantial risk to public health
the variant has an unusually large
number of mutations the plan a uh
policies that we put in place they
remain uh the policies i think that that
we need at this time but she won't be
surprised to know that we do keep this
under review and if we need to go
further we will the new variant center
shudder through global markets the ftse
100 tumbling more than 3 percent after
overnight falls in asia and wall street
followed suit
in london's west end shoppers kept calm
and carried on looking for black friday
bargains but on the cusp of the party
season with hospitality and retail
desperate for a christmas boost the new
variant stirs memories of last winter it
will have sent a chill through the
hospitality sector and also the retail
sector into their golden quarter the
busiest trading period of all with a
fear that there may be further
restrictions coming down the track
should this emerge
a year ago these streets were almost
deserted as britain emerged from one
lockdown unaware that a new variant was
about to prompt a six-month shutdown
today that feels like a distant memory
and it is too early to say whether the
new variant poses a similar threat but
it is a reminder that the pandemic is
far from over
with 80 percent of the population double
vaccinated and 30 having had a booster
britain is far better protected than a
year ago but
b-11529 is an unknown quantity if it's
already been identified say in belgium
you can't rely on country of origin
of traveler origin we think we have to
assume
that people can pick it up and so
everybody should be doing pcr tests i
think we should consider
reinstituting isolation on return from
international travel in general pfizer
says it could have a new vaccine ready
in 100 days if required but that's three
months the other side of a winter that
suddenly feels a little longer paul
kelso sky news